boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation i'm your host alan sachin we
are at the transformative technology
conference so fun here so many diverse
leaders we are now sitting down with dr
daniel stickler hello
nice to be here thank you for coming on
to the show greatly appreciate it
and so as we talk about appear on which
you're co-founder of and um the medical
director for neurohacker
collective so there's a lot to talk
about regarding the the disruption of
well-being into our ecosystems and so
we'll get there we'll talk about that i
want to ask you how you became who you
are today like what led you up to
you now okay i'll try to keep it as
short as possible because it is a long
story
i always wanted to be a doctor i always
looked at
physicians though from the perspective
of
the role is to really enhance health
i got into medical school and i realized
the role was
to
move away from disease
and it wasn't about enhancing health you
know moving towards something really
awesome versus moving away from
something really bad
and
you know it became about pharmacology
and disease and when i was in medical
school i looked at the different options
for what i could do
to still at least kind of fit into my
perception of what i should be doing
and i found surgery so i became a
general vascular surgeon it gave me the
ability to take somebody with a certain
quality of life and i could either bring
them at least back to baseline
or i did some weight loss surgery so i
was able to work with
people who had fairly low quality of
life and i was able to elevate them to
to a new level
and
for a time that seemed to be satisfying
that that need that i had to to fill
that role
but over time i also realized it wasn't
the right way to do it and it wasn't
accomplishing
what i was wanting to do started getting
into wellness as kind of a hobby i
started doing health optimization
with with clients in a concierge style
practices a little side
job that i
truly it was a hobby i wasn't making any
money it was just something i enjoyed
doing
and
eventually i just said one day i said
i'm done i'm not going to do surgery
anymore i walked out of the operating
room and canceled all the rest of my
surgeries i had 800 waiting lists for
weight loss surgery
um wow people thought i lost my mind and
i was like no i'm going to do this full
time
wow yeah and i started getting into
genetics uh kind of self-taught in the
genetic and epigenetic realm and
developed a very
biospecific
personalized approach to healthcare
and dang just that moment i'm happy you
knew from much from childhood that you
wanted to to do to be a doctor because
um sometimes it's uh
well first of all there's a lot of
there's a lot of uh
societal pressure to
to figure out what one wants to do and
so many people are like oh what are you
gonna do when you're older and stuff
anyway we go down that rabbit hole but i
i like i like how you knew what you
wanted to do you figured it out quickly
and then you went and did it and as you
were doing it you figured out that you
wanted to transition into a very similar
field of health and wellness but you
wanted to do it at a point of of of
making people better um
of uh at
rather than having the disease and then
being better you know
to prevent a disease from even occurring
in the first place
seems to be a common tread here which i
really like
now
you know what for for you for that you
know for that transition for you to um
to uh appear on is and that was that's
where appear that is what appears on the
birth of the pure on right okay cool
and then so tell us about that you're
studying genomics
epigenetics and genetics and then you're
um
and you're figuring out kind of the
strong practices for maintaining good
health is that right
well what i
what happened it was kind of this
epiphany that
i realized that
and it was funny because i was reading
uh ishmael by daniel quinn at the time
and it hit me
and i was like
this is what's wrong the medical system
is broken to the point where it's not
something that we can
shift
it's broken to the point where we have
to just
walk away and create something different
yeah
the reason is is because
the current medical system and
healthcare and wellness even in general
it's based on the premise that the human
system is a complicated system
and that's why we have algorithms and
things like that you know your
cholesterol is this and you have this
blood pressure you know these are the
medications
algorithm-based
um
problem is the human system is not
complicated it's complex and you can't
apply
complicated intelligence to a complex
system it doesn't work
the complex system is just highly
variable i mean truly the medical system
looks at the human system as a robot
that has a completely reductionistic
approach
it has
predictable outcomes for everything
and yet we know
there is no predictability
and
it is just
everything interacts in the human system
i mean dna
dna the molecule is the most
intelligently designed molecule i've
ever seen i mean the more i learn about
it the more i'm just fascinated by dna
yeah i mean you're talking about a
molecule that is the core of everything
we know of life
and
it is constantly
assessing our environment
and making changes in its expression
to thrive in that environment yeah
constant adaptation
to
the environment and
it contains memories
it holds memories of your ancestors
in that genetic code and that we're
seeing this now in epigenetics and
transgenerational epigenetics where
we're seeing
the ability to
analyze this code and see how it's being
passed and it's just fascinating stuff i
love how you poeted that that was
beautifully said
it's not only the molecule of life but
it's also the
takes on the epigenetics of the
environment learns how to thrive in that
environment so
so now um yeah where does a puren come
into
to play then with us so knowledge we
developed our medical program which
we've been doing since
really 2012
in this model
and
i was giving presentations
at medical conferences and physicians
kept asking me if i could teach them how
to do what i was doing
never thought about it and i thought
well yeah i guess i could so we started
developing some training modules and
working with some clinicians one-on-one
that eventually in 2015 led us opening
the apparent academy which is a training
ground for basically any anybody so
anybody interested in health and we have
we currently have 160 coaches in the
in the training or have completed it and
they 30 are physicians 30 chiropractors
and the other 40 percent
you name it um
dietitians psychologists pharmacists
nurses health coaches general biohackers
that just want to get into this
so it's a new paradigm it's not a
changing of the old paradigm and you
know the greeks had it right from the
get-go the greeks knew
epigenetics they knew complex systems
and we messed it up um you look back at
even the term dietetica dietetica
was about man's whole way of living
the true definition of it and it talked
about the way he slept
the way he worked
the interaction with his family and the
food he ate and how much he ate yeah i
mean that was the initial
grounds of hippocratic medicine yeah
and those variables are
what makes a life thrive or can just
make a life really miserable right
everything goes into that system and the
system responds to it
yep and that's what we've missed we have
stovepiped everything i mean oh you look
at
what will kill
top 10 killers kill 75 percent of
americans are
you know heart disease and cancer one
and two
but if you look at all those top 10
common causes of death
every single one of them is lifestyle
related
and yet how do we address them well type
2 diabetes well we change their diet we
give them medication
it's the whole lifestyle though that
created the problem in the first place
same with heart disease the same with
with asthma same with accidents you know
we don't even think about accidents
being lifestyle related
but the most common cause of accidents
is sleep deprivation
and sleep is probably the most common
lifestyle intervention that we work with
in clients
wow sleep is the most common
change interesting that people are just
not sleeping eight hours a
night i don't think any i mean it's like
a two percent of the population actually
get the full compliment of sleep in a
night you gotta there's no other way to
do it i mean
the interesting thing is the sleep genes
are some of the oldest genes in all of
life
we share sleep genes with insects i mean
that's how prolific the sleep genes are
and we haven't selected out short sleep
you know even things short sleep would
be a survival benefit you know the
caveman that she sleeps less time is
less vulnerable to predation or anything
like that so those that slept less would
probably be selected out to be the ones
that passed on the genes
didn't happen maybe even if you stayed
in the safe cave and you slept longer
that you would have less time out in the
environment therefore that's a
possibility too
but you would think that you know there
would be a benefit to sleeping less
that's what most people perceive
but from a
development and an ancestral genetic
standpoint we don't see that so there
must be something really important about
getting that sleep totally
interesting that that's like one of the
first
variables that needs to be tweaked for
for people now so now what does it look
like to
uh
you know you're traveling you're all
these physicians were really interested
in getting onboarded um and you have a
lot of people that are not just
physicians like you were listing all the
other people that are
that go through your program so
so what what happens when they sign up
for the program what do they learn and
what do they go and teach than other
people
so we do 100 hours of online training
training genetics and epigenetics
so the epigenetics are broken into the
modules of the different lifestyle
components
we teach them how to alter gene
expressions through lifestyle components
we teach them what certain lifestyle
components can do to change gene
expressions like lack of sleep and
things like that
so it's about 100 hours of online
training we have a pretty active
private facebook group where we all
interact it's pretty cool because you
have people from every specialty i mean
traditional chinese medicine
and
allopathic doctors having discussions
about a particular case that they're
working on or a client that they have
and everybody's contributing equally
judgment-free zone i mean it's amazing
the tribe that's been created with that
group
yeah i want to be in that facebook group
to learn from everyone in there i'm
going to request to join that group
um is there a
you know it would like walk us through a
someone that becomes a
one that takes on appearon's uh
processes so i go through 100 hours of
training i learn about
genetics and epigenetics i learned about
them in all the different
variations of the lifestyles uh changes
and variables that we were talking about
and then
then i go and i apply what i learned to
as a life coach or a physician to
our populations of people that they were
right because we we see that as the next
kind of the next need you know everybody
talks about disposition shortage we
don't have a
health care crisis
we have a lifestyle crisis we need
lifestyle coaches
we don't need more physicians
okay
we need people that can spend that time
i mean when i work with a client i'm on
a video call for 30 to 40 minutes once a
month
every month for 12 months i'm
interacting with them as part of our
interaction
so they're getting six hours a year a
year minimum of face time with me yeah
and we work with every aspect of their
health so every call i'm talking about
what's working with this what's not
working with this what's the next step
what does your biometric device tell me
about your sleep uh you know when your
doctor's creeping on your sleep you're a
little bit like okay maybe i need to get
those eight hours yeah
yeah and and we
teach the coaches the same thing so the
coaches can work with it and and we're
not talking about a
financial model that's out of range for
everybody because
we have a wide growth of coaches
that
all have trained under the same platform
they may not have the same credentials
but they're also not going to charge the
same fees for this
and this can be a model that a physician
group can adopt and actually utilize in
that regard
but with this we teach them to bio
individualize the approach so there's
nothing cookie cutter about what we do
everything is about how is this person a
unique individual we look at their
genetics
we have our own genetic tests that we do
similar to the 23andme but it's a very
private and
you own your own data we don't share we
don't sell nothing like that we have
genetic reports that we work with we
train the coaches and the clinicians on
how to interpret those reports
so you actually have somebody that can
interpret your genetics for you
and then with those genetics they can be
very
individualized and biospecific about you
know this is a
nutritional pattern that has the highest
probability of working well for you
this is an exercise pattern based on
your goals
that will
most likely get you there
but it's not a matter of absolutes we're
not going to say oh this is the perfect
diet
it doesn't exist
we look at it and we say okay is this
diet conducive to your genetics is it
conducive towards your goals and is it
conducive towards
what your desires are as far as food
and if that works then we try it and we
set metrics up so if we can measure it
we can manage it
everything we do
we measure like when when a client comes
in and they say oh i'm on these 20
supplements i'm like okay i need to know
why you're taking each one and what
you're doing to measure the whether it's
working or not yeah
and i can tell you if they can't answer
both of those they get marked off the
list we take them off okay until
the end when i say okay here are the
supplements i would recommend this is
why we're going to take them and this is
what we're going to measure to see if
they work yeah
yeah
man
these
these practices i'm happy that you've
put them into um
into a
curriculum for for people to be able to
access and apply to their lives just
because it's ridiculous if we're if
we're not uh if we don't know the why of
why of why we're doing things and we're
not measuring um just and like you said
we need more lifestyle coaches not
physicians right people that can help us
understand how we can tweak things in
our environment that will help us live
healthier
more emotionally well-being lives yeah
so
okay so how many total people have went
through up here on now do you know as
far as coaches the others code yeah
coaches um
completed the training we've had about
uh 60 60. yeah cool we've got another
100 in the training right now nice
and it takes them how long to 100 hours
is it varies
so they get full access to the course
when they register but
some of them will burn through it in
three to four months and some of them
will take over a year yeah cool okay
and then
um
and then what so what does it what so
how big is the team then your team
our team we have about uh 16 people in
the corporate level 16 people okay
and then the cost of the course is it's
around three thousand dollars three
thousand dollars okay
um and has it been spreading mostly like
word of mouth related it has i i speak
quite a bit
so
a lot of people will hear me when i when
i give talks um
we also
travel around and do
two-day live seminars to give people a
kind of a taste oh sweet of that oh
that's cool when when was the last one
so we were in austin september uh
december we're in sarasota uh then we
are touring australia
new zealand so march is australia new
zealand
and then i think we're coming back to
chicago before
june
two-day workshops and at these workshops
they're learning
what you're teaching we teach them basic
genetics and epigenetics because it's
something that a lot of the healthcare
practitioners are
they kind of dabble in but they're not
really sure of the science of it
you know epigenetics epigenetics was one
of these things that uh
you know bruce lipton was great he
brought it to the forefront
um but i think he took it a little bit
too far into the
you know the pseudoscience world
trying to explain things with it
and a lot of people have adopted it in
pseudoscience to explain the
unexplainable
which
you know
epigenetics has true science behind it i
mean there's over 10 000 peer-reviewed
journal articles published a year
there's over 200 clinical trials
actively going
um and believe it or not it's physicians
that are the most skeptical
about epigenetics uh and yet we have
tons of literature on it yeah
i think once we get to a point where we
understand
uh epigenetics really well i think we
can manifest our destinies better
oh absolutely i mean you know people
will say you know oh i've got
the these genes in my phone i'm like so
what
you know the genes are nothing more than
the code of propensity
their lifestyle is your destiny
that's what you have control over
and you know even people with like the
apoe4 alzheimer's risk gene
you know you can
based on your lifestyle you can have 30
times standard risk but you can also do
lifestyle practices which we've shown in
research that's been able to bring that
risk almost down to average yeah even
with a high risk for developing it yeah
so we know these lifestyle factors have
huge impacts on gene expression damn
i was born with this gene so what
so what you can we can make change we
make change with the way that we behave
in our environments
wow um
now is there something now do you
foresee a future where more people
are
aware of the epigenetic science and that
can like manifest their destiny through
behavior changes and do they themselves
take like a smaller version of your
course to make those changes or do they
always work with like someone that has
taken your full course or how would how
do you see that playing out um
well that that kind of brings up
something
we have transitions of
health progression so we have the
unbalanced state which is what
the hippocratic
medicine did not recognize disease as a
entity they said system was either in
homeostasis or it was unbalanced it's
out of homeostasis
most people are out of homeostasis so
the first step is to get them into
homeostasis
once we're there
then coach physician whoever
can take them and say okay what are your
goals
okay these this is how we can leverage
lifestyle components
to
change gene expressions to optimize
your functioning as a human being
we see another phase of this though and
this is the enhanced human face and i
mean even
even stephen hawking's in his final book
said
gene editing's coming and we are going
to see the enhanced human beings
and you either accept it or you become a
slave to those
and
um
you know that's something that
a lot of people are uncomfortable with
but for me
to think that homo sapien is the end
point of evolution is a bit naive
totally and we are the first species
to ever take the reigns of evolution
into our own hands
and we should get good at it
and practice it yeah and have
stewardship for earth and yeah
practically you know it it amazes me
that
you know they did a study asking people
if they were okay with gene editing and
it was like okay we're okay if a child
is going to be born with
a
life-threatening disease or a birth
defect or something like that we're okay
with gene editing
but
we're not okay with gene editing to make
people smarter stronger faster but
that's
so yeah but that's what we do every day
is we try and make ourselves smarter and
stronger we do and and
you know i say
what is one thing that can potentially
have such a profound impact on
society
smart people
yes you know we become more intelligent
we become more empathetic empathetic we
become more compassionate
we
are able to
create solutions
to a lot of the problems that we've
created already so what is wrong with
creating a smarter human being
i wonder if still i'm curious if it's
going to end up being something that you
know if if i can access appear on in a
smaller
dose to be to to have a like a that
small dose of here's a behavior change i
can do that can immediately start
affecting me positively without having
to learn everything to and not
everything but a lot and then um well
and see this comes down to the complex
nature of the human being
every piece of the environment interacts
it's just like
you know height
height from a genetic standpoint
we used to think that there we could
identify a gene for height then we said
okay well it's polygenic it means
there's 10 20 genes that that are
involved in determining height well then
they found out that yeah the key 20
genes account for about one percent of
height
differences
the new model is
that the entire genome
contributes to every trait that we have
and it's the same with lifestyle
everything within lifestyle contributes
to outcome so when we work with somebody
somebody may come in and they say well
you know i have diabetes and and this
that and the other thing and i'm like i
don't care here's what we're going to do
we're going to work on your sleep we're
going to work on your stress we're going
to work on your nutrition we're going to
work on your supplementation we're going
to work on your hormones we're going to
work on your movement and exercise and
we're going to work on mitigating your
environment
yeah we work on all seven categories
simultaneously it's not a matter of
focusing on one that's old medicine
model yeah so you know people will say
well fix my sleep well
are you eating right
how's your stress
you know what's your relationship like
yeah you know we have to hit all these
things because
the answers aren't in these individual
pieces it's like people looking for that
limitless pill
doesn't exist and it's not going to
exist
you've got to do other things
simultaneously in order for that to
occur yeah i like how you're making that
really clear um you've got to have a
solid understanding of those seven major
categories of wellness
right and pursue
uh
conscientious
pursuit with yourself an honest goal
setting an achievement with yourself in
those in those fields
um
is there something else that we should
mention dan about appear on or about
what you're building that we missed that
you think is really important we are
building an ai platform
now this is going to be
a whole different approach based on
on our model but
uh the ai platform is going to
incorporate everybody's genetic data
their lab work
their supplements their medications
their
their lifestyle
and
the really nice thing about it is we're
going to incorporate our coaches to help
make sure that this is maintained yeah
and
we're going to incorporate biometric
monitoring devices but we're also going
to have subjective
confirmation
on these devices on this platform
and i know there's a lot of people out
there developing platforms but
we have we're leveraging our
distribution network with the coaches
to help make this work you know a lot of
these companies are trying to get all
these people in and they they're great
for about a month and then people drop
off they quit doing it
with the accountability of the coaches
we think we can develop a platform
that will get real actionable data and
we will start seeing interactions so
you have this this gene you took this
supplement this is the common outcome
yes we're seeing in this group of people
yes and it's all going to be
kind of crowdsourced
so
everybody
is going to voluntarily be on this
platform that wants to be
so you choose to share your data on this
platform in exchange for getting the
benefits of being in that group yeah
we're not going to share the data we're
not going to sell the data it's the same
with our genetic testing we don't do any
of that
finding the patterns i love that i'm
really happy that you brought that up
because when you find the patterns it
makes it so you don't have to do the
trial and errors again and again yeah
yeah you get it
and there's there's going to be a lot of
variables to to crunch oh yeah i mean
it's going to take a quantum computer at
some point to
crunch and it's because the human system
is unpredictable
it is a highly variable system and and
you hit the nail on the head there i
mean
that's the problem with the current
system as it's based on that assumption
of an algorithm works and yeah
that would assume that we were computers
and robots yeah and like you said it's a
specific you know maybe a specific
supplement for a specific element for a
specific gene to change
you know a specific exercise routine for
specific you know demographic people or
that have a certain ailment you know
there's yeah it's just
yeah this is it's very tough to figure
it out but once we get the the kind of
this fundamental layer of principles and
research that at least we can build on
top we need to build
at least that layer and keep building
the layers on top and if new
advancements come then we can go has to
be dynamic yes yes i mean research alone
is broken right now because it's based
on
a non-uniform population but it makes
the assumption that the population is
uniform yeah and that's where it's not
working and this is where it has to come
down to this dynamic
this has been super interesting dan i'm
really happy that you're building this
into our world and this is
i i personally i need to learn more
about epigenetics i need to learn more
about how we behave in our in our
environments in these seven categories
that you listen and really dive deep
into into i always i always say like
when i ask people questions i'm like
look in the mirror and ask yourself
these questions too and so you know how
oft am i
you know the quantified self movement
will help us a lot um if we actually
take that onto ourselves and be like you
know i can't lie because my
my my dad is clear that i wasn't
sleeping or exercising my heart rate's
been the same all day you know or
yeah
um awesome so that was a lot of fun
thank you for teaching us i really
appreciate it thank you for coming onto
the show thanks for having me that was a
lot of fun and uh everyone um go check
out the link in the bio to appear on
please go check them out also
check out transformative technology
conference link in the bio as well in
their academy
also go and leave us some comments we'd
love to hear from you about what you
know about epigenetics about what you
know about changing your behaviors and
your environments and how that affects
you we'd love to you know like we said
start the conversation and keep up
building onto that foundation of
knowledge that we're pursuing
also go and build the future go manifest
your dreams into the world thanks
everyone for tuning in we appreciate it
and we'll see you soon peace
nice thank you so much that was fun
i'm glad you had a good time